The artists at Walt Disney Animation may have
traded their pencils and notepads for computers
and keyboards over the years, but not everything
has changed.
Decades of Disney heroes are too beloved to
be forgotten, which means plenty of Easter
Eggs, secret cameos, and inside jokes to watch
out for.
Here is our list of 10 Hidden Details in Disney
Movies.
Frozen
Long before Anna, Elsa, and Olaf became household
names, the makers of Frozen had a party to
plan.
Being named Queen of Arrendale may have stressed
Elsa out, but it also meant the gates of the
castle would finally be opened to villagers
and visiting guests.
When Anna finally steps out of the gates,
two arriving villagers should stand out to
Disney fans: Rapunzel and Flynn Rider, the
stars of Disney's Tangled.
Big Hero 6
As one of the most successful movies Disney
has ever released, we're willing to bet that
Easter Eggs and references to Frozen are just
beginning.
The minds behind Big Hero 6 are clearly fans
- and hold a serious grudge against Hans,
the would-be king who tried to kill both of
Frozen's leading ladies.
A statue of Hans can be seen for just a moment
before Baymax destroys it while trying out
his new armor.
If that weren't enough, his face can be seen
gracing a Wanted poster in a San Fransokyo
police station.
The Little Mermaid
It seems Disney animators never miss a chance
to fill crowd scenes with iconic characters
from other movies and cartoons, even before
Easter Eggs were mandatory.
When King Triton assembles the underwater
masses in the opening scene of The Little
Mermaid, eagle-eyed viewers can spot Donald
Duck, Goofy, and Mickey Mouse in the crowd.
And it isn't just Disney mascots who get in
on the fun, either: Kermit the Frog can be
seen just a few rows behind them.
Lilo & Stitch
You don't have to be a princess just to star
in a Disney adventure, only willing to don
a disguise to protect your family - and belt
out a few musical numbers too.
Mulan learned that for herself when she pretended
to be a man to join China's forces against
the invading Huns in Disney's retelling of
the classic story.
Its message must have struck a chord with
the cast of Lilo and Stitch, since a poster
of Mulan hangs on Lilo's mother Nani's wall,
and the family even passes a restaurant called
"Mulan Wok" when first adopting the trouble-making
alien.
Wall-E
Trading a human or animal star for a robotic
one, Wall-E was a major turning point for
Pixar as a whole, relying less on dialogue
than ever before.
Set in a future where mankind has turned Earth
into one massive landfill and headed into
space, Wall-E is just one maintenance robot
left behind.
He's put his time to good use, too, collecting
dozens of trinkets and souvenirs to store
in his home.
When Wall-E first enters his house in the
movie, one Toy Story character can be seen
hidden behind a pair of bowling pins.
How Rex managed to survive the man-made end
of the world isn't clear, but if he survived,
then it stands to reason Woody and the gang
were still alive off-screen as well
The Hunchback of Notre Dame
Few Disney movies can compete with the number
of cameos tucked into The Hunchback of Notre
Dame, with the opening scene alone featuring
a vendor selling Aladdin's magic carpet, and
Beauty and the Beast's Belle out for a morning
stroll.
The Lion King jokester Pumbaa seems the odd
one out, but his other cameo in the films
climax is even better: proudly standing guard
as a stone gargoyle.
Brave
When Pixar was made an official branch of
Walt Disney Animation, the tradition of Easter
Eggs and cameos was just one thing both studios
could agree on - even if it made no sense
to the story being told.
It's strange enough that among the wooden
carvings being sold by the Witch in Brave
is the same Pizza Planet delivery truck included
in every Pixar film.
But the carved image of Sully, the furry star
of the wildly successful Monsters, Inc. shows
that even witches need to worry about what's
hiding in their closet.
Beauty and the Beast
One of the best known Pixar Easter Eggs is
the label "A113", the classroom at the California
Institute of Technology where many of the
company's earlier animators learned their
trade.
But the California locations are nothing new:
in Beauty and The Beast, Maurice and Felipe
find themselves lost in a terrifying forest,
with a worn-out signpost offering little help.
But a closer look shows arrows pointing to
both Valencia, where the school is located,
and Anaheim, home to Disneyland.
Ratatouille
In what may be Pixar’s most unconventional
tale to date, Ratatouille follows a rat with
a flair for the culinary arts, and a young
man named Linguini who hopes to become a great
chef, but lacks the skills to do it.
The pair realizes success means combining
their talents, but actually working together
poses a serious challenge.
When Linguini considers smuggling Remy into
the kitchen in his pants, the rat isn’t
on board.
But the biggest reveal of the scene is Linguini’s
underwear, shown to be patterned with the
logo of Mr. Incredible, the star of The Incredibles.
It’s one more hint that Pixar’s films
all take place in one universe, while also
showing that superheroes are just as famous
in the fictional world of Pixar as they are
in our own.
A Dog Eat Dog World
There's one fact that no one can deny: the
Disney animators are most certainly dog people.
And what's better than a canine adventure?
How about a shared universe of them?
101 Dalmatians has enough spotted dogs in
a single family to worry about, but when the
call goes out that the pups are in trouble,
Lady and the Tramp can be seen in the city
streets, along with their canine co-stars
Jock and Peg.
The litter's father, Pongo also makes a Cameo
in Oliver & Company, along with Jock, Peg,
and the always loyal Trusty.
So what do you think of our list?
Did we miss any of your favorite Disney easter
eggs or inside jokes?
Let us know in our comment section and don't
forget to subscribe to our channel for more
videos like this one.